Chris John congratulations you guys have
made it into the third round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forges to recreate this
iconic weapon from American history
General Patton saber
in this free test I'll be doing patent
saber
you can see that it comes and tapers to
a point so automatically I think pointy
says hey you gotta thrust with that and
then it's a double-edged weapon okay
then you're supposed to slash with that
it's a light weapon for movement but the
damages can do deep thrust deep Cuts
renowned for his expertise in tank
warfare during World War One and Two
General George S Patton of the U.S army
was also an exceptional swordsman and
Olympic fencer his signature sword of
his own design the m1913 saber was built
based on his saber training in France
the lethal blade was known for being a
vicious Thruster both on Horseback where
the speed of the horse and the Precision
strike of the point inflicted maximum
bodily destruction
hand on foot where a soldier could use
lunges in Paris to attack their enemies
although General Patton perished in
Germany shortly after the second world
war his legacy lives on through his
swords design which is now revered as a
prized artifact among collectors
foreign
on the pre-test we get to use the blades
made by Dave Baker and that's nice about
it because Dave is a great sword maker
so the balance feel and function is
always there so at least I have an idea
of what to expect how this should move
according to what's being presented
good luck we'll see you in four days
foreign
Ville South Carolina I'm 35 years old
and I am absolutely a Metalhead from way
back I think I'm going to be old and
bald and still thrashing out with my
goat horns up I've got this big old
chunk of 5160 spring steel here I think
it's going to make a really nice sword
weapons quite light and thin challenge
is keeping this thing straight As I
Forge it and I think if I can accomplish
that I'll be okay
hmm
I picked up a little bit of a curve in
this thing I don't want to waste too
much more time chasing it out there's
always a chance a lot of it will come
back out once they dip it in the clinch
I believe my blade has gotten hot enough
I am ready to quench
I do still have a fairly significant
s-curve warp to it so I quickly throw it
between a couple of big chunks of wood
to see if I can address the warp if this
doesn't work I'm screwed
okay
I've got a very very slight warble right
towards the end but I'm positive I could
take it out with the grinder so we might
be in good shape
feel pretty good about that once I have
my wood block shaped for my handle I
start figuring out how I'm going to try
to make this back strap got this old
kind of cool looking spoon of unknown
metal I think it's some sort of steel
plated and some sort of other metal but
it looks cool and I'm going to beat and
Bash and bend it until it fits around
the back of my handle all right I get it
glued up to the rest of the sword now
once my epoxy sets it's going to be time
to move it on to sharpening
so this blade is as sharp as a razor and
it's ready for testing
we'll cut
foreign
my name is John McNerney 20 years ago I
got into horseshoeing and problem with
making a horseshoe is that horse steps
in a pile of manure so that's why I like
making knives they stay around and they
stay nice I'm making a ladder pattern
Damascus build I'm stacking 1085 and 15
in 20. this is a large blade and there
can be a lot of things that go wrong
with this much forging so I'm not
comfortable putting all my eggs just in
that one Billet so my plan is to make a
5160 boat so I have insurance that'll
have a good blade for this build I
really want the Damascus to be my sword
so I started grinding on it
and right away I start seeing some
delaminations in this edge here
they want to fall apart
I'm gonna scrap the Damascus save it for
the back strap and move on to the 5160
and make that my blade I'm not going to
take a risk with ten thousand dollars on
the line
I go to the forge get it hot and I go on
the quick state
when I pull this knife out of the oil I
have a nice straight sword
so it's time to get the guard started to
go up to the plasma cutter and we cut
out a piece of sheet metal that's going
to become our guard I'm a horse shoeer
they have horses put a horse on it horse
head for the cowboy sword this is my
version of the Cowboys Cavalry sword
say that twice
I'm going to acid extra guard black and
I'm going to put some enamel over the
top just to preserve it and then find
the inside of the guard with pig leather
so make sure it's nice and comfy for
their hands I finished assembling the
sword just with enough daylight to be
able to test it
this is whiskey
okay it worked
welcome to the kill test your Sabers
look deadly
to find it out I will take your weapon
delivers some slashes and thrusts on
this ballistic stump
your first you ready for this
yeah
[Music]
foreign
it's just not right
all right John first stop let's talk
about the handle construction it's a
little bit on the big side but I'm able
to hold on to it now your Edge
it's very sharp and it is a pleasure to
wield because aside from looking
beautiful it'll kill
thank you very much
all right Chris your turn are you ready
sir yes sir I sure am
[Music]
all right Chris let's talk about your
saber here first up what I love about it
it's got a sharp edge every swing I do
cuts the one thing here is that you did
pick up a little bit of a Bend right
here at this Junction
it's warped a little bit
but it pierces and cuts and most
importantly
it will kill like dessert
blade Smiths for your General Patton
saber will kill for that you deserve a
general path on the back
next up a strength test Jay
all right blade Smith for a strength
test I'm going to take your Sabers and
I'm going to beat them and stab them
into these field obstacles now I'm not
really concerned about where your swords
do to our obstacles I want to see the
opposite what they do to your swords
John you at first you ready to go ready
to go all right let's do it
foreign
nice job John I like the blade the sword
itself overall is on the heavy side the
handle is a lot there a lot of extra
weight it does help counterbalance quite
a bit though
still got a good Edge on it there's some
pretty heavy strikes on there the blade
bent but came back to true it's all
right tight and straight good job thank
you how you feeling Chris
good as I can be sir all right
here
oh
okay no cuts no but
lucky day
Chris your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our strength
test and unfortunately you cannot
continue with testing which means you
cannot beat the forest fire champion
please exit the forge
well John General Patton was known for
being a tough guy and you made a tough
and sharp sword that really honors his
name congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job thank you thank you how
do you feel right now
[Applause]
all right man come on over and Shake our
hands good job brother it's a beautiful
sword yeah I'm the new Forge and fire
champion
phenomenal jumping on hatred thank you
sir I'm proud of what I did and it's
been a fun deal hey can I get a fortune
fire Bob Buckle now no belt buckle come
on